We found out that the measure of the angle was 10 degrees. We really should make
sure that this is correct. Let's make sure we can check this with our ideas of
supplement and complement. We know the complement of angle x has to be 80
degrees, since 80 and 10 make 90 degrees. And the supplement of angle x has to
be 170 degrees, since these two add up to 180. So, in my equation, I can replace
the complement with 80 degrees and the supplement with 170 degrees. This allows
me to check my work. I want to know if this answer is really true. Was the
supplement 10 more than two times the complement? And yes, 170 degrees is equal
to 170 degrees. Our supplement was double the complement plus 10. So we can be
assured that our answer was correct. The unknown angle was 10 degrees.